let's pull up this story here from
timcast.com
senator lindsey graham proposes
nationwide 15-week abortion ban grams of
the legislation is comparable to
abortion regulations in 47 european
countries the republicans don't have the
senate the house or the executive branch
so there's no point in introducing this
bill other than to virtual signal or
sabotage the republicans right before
the midterm election
i mean you can argue that maybe he's
like
look we're going to do this
if you vote for us we will do this
because that will rally not just
democrats but also republicans but
republicans are already angry they're
already ready to vote out democrats
democrats are the ones who need to be
riled up
so it seems like lindsey graham is just
sabotaging the republicans i think he's
an insulated guy like he's insulated in
his his you know
echo chamber and thinks that he's doing
moral good by his what he believes that
he really believes and wants that i i
don't i don't agree with you he's an
establishment neocon that has been
always toting the line of the party
establishment no matter what it is and
he always is on the tip of the sphere
when it comes to pushing this larger
agenda that screws everyone else over it
wouldn't surprise me if this was a
bigger play to screw over uh you know
the big part of the republican party
that is set to allegedly win in this
upcoming election you look at how you
know the abortion ruling by the supreme
court mobilized a whole bunch of
activists a whole bunch of people to get
active inside of democratic states and
cities all throughout the united states
why bring up this issue when of course
this is only showing the enemy your move
even if it's that but i don't think it's
that i think it's what tim is asserting
it is and i think this is a deliberate
action to shoot in the foot the kind of
populist uprising that he wants to quail
so he you think he he wants
trump or any republican to fail so that
the unit the liberal economic order can
seize control and so he's just shoving a
nail in it with this well this is going
to mobilize i think a lot of people and
i think if you look at his voting record
it's always been not just you know
republican uh or democratic it's always
been pro establishment pro ruling party
pro billionaire class pro world economic
forum he has always voted along those
particular lines so it wouldn't surprise
me if he's now intervening as many
people like joe rogan are telling people
to go vote republican
and i think this is going to have an
effect on it
it's habitat
yeah do you think that someone would
sabotage their own political party is
very very weird but he's not really he's
not aligned with the populist
republicans he's aligned with with neo
the democrats he's had a history of that
i mean and look at uh liz cheney i mean
she's a republican she's
is there anybody that has uh sabotaged
the the maga movement more or tried to
sabotage the maga movement more than her
i mean i think he is an establishment
guy that tends to go along like mccain
did
with the democrats on certain kinds of
issues and this just doesn't make any
sense it goes against the entire
argument for roe v wade and getting rid
of it was to give this off to the states
and allow states to make up their own
mind on this that was the argument from
the right and now he's completely
usurping that he's saying no we actually
want more than that and to do this right
now before an election i mean does he
have some kind of polling numbers that
say something different i don't know i
think we saw what happened in kansas
when they put it on the bill they put an
amendment uh i think it was kansas was
yeah it was kansas but they put a the
abortion bill on their amendment ended
getting vote voted down resoundingly
voted down he's helping democrats that
simple 100 because now every single
democrat is going to have campaign ads
saying senator lindsey graham
wants a nationwide abortion ban
and they got it i guess if you if like
cultural military you know war gaming
here if you had a country and there was
a a revolt in one of your cities and you
couldn't get the r the rebels out of
your city that you would scorch dirt the
city and burn it all down even though
it's your city so if he's afraid that
the magga have taken over the republican
party that he would sabotage the
republican party that's not out of the
realm of possibility no it's not and if
they if they do not have the red wave
that so many on the right are hoping for
what does that say
who who ends up benefiting from that i
think it ends up being you know i think
trump ends up not benefiting from that
and the establishment republicans they
like they've done with illegal
immigration for years they misrepresent
or they misinterpret
a an election outcome to benefit their
own positions and they've done it with
illegal immigration in the past where
where somebody would lose and they'd say
okay that was because they took a hard
line against illegal immigration we need
to go amnesty the way that the left is
doing and and lindsay is a perfect
example of of somebody that's completely
bought into the establishment is also
really good friends with joe biden and
again said that joe biden is a good man
as quote as god has ever created so he's
been very anti-trump very anti-populist
very pro-john mccain neocon
neoconservative trying to start foreign
wars every chance every instance he gets
so he's definitely not working in the
interest of the american people he's
working towards the interest of the
military industrial complex and the
ruling party since you know the
connection with biden is very clear with
him and uh you know biden being in the
senate you know for 720 years now uh
they had a very long cozy relationship
yeah he was in the roman senate yeah
it's true yeah
i i wonder if lindsay was bullied when
he was a kid because it kind of feels
like this is what someone that's like
the target of being bullied grows up and
then they get power and now then they
become a bully it's a problem with
bullying man right just an evil guy you
know just evil
man
you know in my younger days i did not
believe in good and evil
i was just like no i think it's it's you
know people are trying their best but
they just disagree on how you go about
things and then you get into
you know an industry industry like this
you're like oh no they're evil
they're literally just even crazy things
when people believe they're doing good
because like everybody thinks they're
the hero in their own story so when
people believe they're doing good while
they're doing evil acts it's really good
but that's easy but but i but i think
some of them just evil like they i used
to think that i used to think everybody
was the hero of their own story and then
i was like wow and then you have to
realize no some people are evil some of
them are just like how much collateral
damage can we sustain they told me that
they said occupy wall street they said
don't you want to just watch it all burn
and i said not really and they're like i
was thinking about 911 and if that
really was perpetrated by someone other
than who we think it was or even even if
there was more involvement than what we
were told that they're like how many
people can we kill and destroy in order
to get a war going so that we can start
profiting in the middle east so it's
beyond that and i think when we talk
about a larger spiritual energetic war i
think there's more reality to this
that's very hard to quantify in words
because there are individuals in our
society just like the new science
advisor in the in the in the biden
administration that literally takes all
of his human liquids and writes demonic
words on walls with them in order to
summon demons and does things like
spirit cooking
with
podesta uh
uh tony podesta that's john's brother
he's pretty crazy i've heard yeah
there's john podesta of course you know
my favorite cooking my favorite meme
paintings was the uh police sketch of
the people who kidnapped that little
girl and it just you not seen this oh
yeah i seen this yeah the police
sketcher like here's the peop
people of interest in the in the case of
this missing young girl and it looks
just like the podesta brothers yes yeah
exactly like that yeah like there's even
a mole on the face it's like that's
weird yeah tony john's brother john just
got tapped for biden's what is he what's
his position now in the biden
administration john's in there now you
remember what what breitbart said
what did you say you guys don't know no
you guys don't know what you're saying
yeah about podesta uh-huh but tony tony
has been known to be like a wild wild
one yeah that's john he can't control
what your brother does but that's still
like you know i don't know how connected
they have a consulting group that of
course andrew breitbart tweeted february
4th 2011
how prague guru john podesta isn't
household name as world-class underage
sex slave op cover-up or defending
unspeakable dregs escapes oh my wow
that's a lot very crazy thing for a man
to say that's like back in the day when
no one knew who podesta was when you're
connected to the secretary of state like
he was with hillary you've got access to
all the information of what's going on
he might have known if tony was doing
stuff and like what are you it's his
brother so like well do you have your
brother arrested i mean in a just
society yes but in a nepotistic thing
you you know we see maybe not well they
they ran a consulting group together
that worked with a lot of foreign
governments that worked with saudi
arabia that worked with a lot of death
spots
and if you look at the the work that
they've done it's it's really kind of
scary and eye-opening how much influence
that they had they were pretty much the
right-hand man for hillary clinton and
bill clinton and those are some dirty
hands to have john podesta yeah uh yes
john podesta specifically i i
interviewed john podesta uh before uh
he's also big into aliens and ufos lots
of weird stuff with him and the
paintings and the art that they have we
could go down the rabbit hole what if
what if the reality is that uh
aliens just you know run things aliens
and and that's that explains everything
that's the next false fight according to
eddie bravo every one of these
politicians are aliens they've been
allowed to stay in this for too long not
every one year i don't know none of the
politicians are aliens like deserts
they're just kidding they're human
beings and there are aliens who are like
we run this you're a chicken coop and
you do as you're told
[Music]
they've been in power for too
long i was doing we did this thing
recently where we're looking for clips
from the 1972 election and i'm looking
at election night uh footage and who's
who are they talking about joe biden
yeah 1972
50 years ago this guy has been in this
and when you're in dc for that long you
understand all the loopholes all the ins
and outs the positions that you need to
make money to to flow money to the big
guy to how to get your family in there
and and and bifurcate you know
investigations and what have you there
are smart people that have been in in dc
for a very long time that have become
evil this is my fun conspiracy theory
joke that uh
the answer to fermi's paradox is that
aliens do exist they did come here
they've taken over and the reason we're
seeing such weird and rapid changes to
our culture and society is because the
point at which they began is the point
at which the aliens showed him and said
all right we're taking over you can't
stop us we have laser guns
and then the world leaders were like
well okay i guess a good example of um
the fun thought
is an episode of stargate
sg-1 where
for those that are familiar with it
basically there's a planet
it's very advanced and then the people
living there don't realize that they had
already been secretly conquered by the
the evil alien race or whatever and so
everything seems to be normal but then
they find out actually the government
was being run by an invading species or
whatever so you know [ __ ] fun fun
conspiracy are the aliens just having
fun with us no no like you know i was
thinking you know you guys are familiar
with fermi's paradox yes
so what
yeah explain that really quick so it's
basically if if the universe is so vast
and expansive then alien life surely
must exist and if so why haven't we
encountered it here are the potential
theories or hypotheses as to why we've
encountered intelligent life and there's
things like the great filter which is
that any sufficiently intelligent life
eventually wipes itself out
there's um i forgot i forgot what some
of the names of these are but some of
them are that sun's basically bursting
beforehand you know cataclysmic events
that take out well that's that's
basically the great filter like life
gets wiped out but there's also things
like um the universe is so big and so
vast that life never appears at the same
time as each other and or it's or it's
so incredibly rare uh so there's a bunch
of different different ideas and my
hypothetical answer is that uh aliens
are abundant and considering the size
and scope of the universe mastering
massive hyper hyper speed travel and uh
we are a bunch of monkeys on a on a
small primitive planet and so they are
a chicken coop
i don't see why aliens would have to be
our size i could imagine that they're
larger than our solar system yeah or
smaller yeah and and we're we're beast
of burden you know what i mean they need
they need specialists with with digits
that can you know build little hardware
and stuff for them so it sounds like
what you're saying because there is the
one of the biggest and earliest media
hoaxes was in the early 1800s where they
i think it was the new york sun did an
article on the moon having uh batman
and uh
it was huge they did like all of these
stories on it and they cited some
some london uh study and to validate
this so it sounds to me like what you're
saying is that story was actually not a
hoax that somehow i'm just kidding
like i think the reality is corrupt
people do corrupt things and burn
everything to the ground like we're
tracking like the roman empire you know
it's it's similar and so we can look to
history and say hey things like this
just happen you know i was thinking
today would you let yourself die to make
everyone else's life better do you think
would you do that today i i have a hard
time saying yes to that because i'm like
those people what did they do for me
what do i like the collective personal
if you said okay this family member this
dot your daughter or your wife for a
second i've actually seen a video on
this recently where they basically asked
women that question would you die
for your
husband or for your boyfriend and tuiti
i know this edited so maybe they didn't
all say that but every single one of
them said no i would not and the man
says they ask the men and all of the men
said yes well come on look i got
chickens outside
and if a fox is lurking up the rooster
will run full speed sacrificing its life
to save the hens and the hens will all
go run to safety yeah he'll die yeah
that's just the way nature
it's what is i got a question though do
you guys think that if you knew the the
collapse the roman empire was coming
would you as an individual be able to
have stopped it
no i don't think at that period of
history no way maybe within
if you have a internet
machine to know exactly how everything
happens maybe you could intervene and
have some kind of impact on it or delay
it significantly i don't think so i
think there's too many things happening
at one time and you know if that's the
case is the collapse of america
inevitable and no no action that we
could do is going to change that but it
always has to start somewhere and then
snowball so if you could go back in time
and stop the snowball stop the crossing
of the rubicon yeah well it was really
stopping the expansion of the roman
state because it was got so big that the
technology couldn't support the
infrastructure and they had to split in
half and then at that point it was just
like just down well i thought the 2020
election was that kind of that
inflection point where you saw this the
entire country burn
and how somebody can vote for the party
that created that that uh chaos
was stunning to me so have we kind of
have we crossed that that point where we
can't reverse i i can't think otherwise
but that we can change it and that we
have the tools to do it and that we have
the ability to do it because otherwise
you know we have no hope no i i don't
think there's no hope i think the system
is crumbling before us but it doesn't
mean that we're going to suffer it just
means that
the world around us will change
substantially and we are going to have
to rebuild
from the uh from the ashes i'm not i
don't see it as a bad thing but people
not paying attention will suffer the
people who are ignorant and don't know
what's going on will suffer everybody
watching this show is going to be all
right i guess because they because they
bought all of their food at
safeandreadymeals.com
i think that they do want to put people
in pods and link them into the metaverse
and somehow extract heat from their body
for electricity and like just sedate a
large population that's the most i get
it but that doesn't actually work the
extracting heat from your body for
energy electric juice i don't know i
mean they're going to try and find a way
to harvest what is sort of electric
juice
electric
electric is when you harness vibration
to create an electrical current okay so
the body's own like your your bones are
made of uh hydroxyapatite which is a
crystal a vibrating crystal for instance
and if you could somehow harness the
vibration to get electricity out of it
and like if you're in a fluid that's
really sensitive to vibration and you
create like a static charge just by
being inside of it
um i would imagine rather than kill
everybody off they're going to try and
extract value from the human body the
environmentalists are going to find some
way for that not to be renewable and uh
and argue against it and protest against
it we have we've been having renewable
things for in renewable technology and
nuclear for 30 40 years and
they've been fighting it for uh for that
long as well because
constantly feeding people is a big
weight on the system and that's what the
world economic forum is interested in
not doing they want to do that less
that's why they're like we want to slow
the growth of population and it's a lot
of it's because they don't think that
they can feed it properly do you think
what's happening right now in regards to
the you know the hitting of the supply
chain and what have you do you think
it's part of a design do you think that
this is actually something that the
world economic forum and those kinds of
globalist uh
overlords are the ones that are are
causing a lot of this supply chain issue
yeah only in that when i think about the
electricity system like why are we still
on a centralized electricity grid when
there are options for localized fusion
reactors or or fission reactors or local
power systems like they have in africa
in a lot of places where they
everybody's got solar on the roof but
they've kept us connected to the grid
because that's the power structure they
the city controls if i have electricity
or not so maybe that they're doing that
with food too i don't that's the only
reason why i think that maybe the food's
also involved in that
food and electricity man if you can
control those you control a nation
so is is the reality that there is no
great crisis but they're manufacturing
it also they can
centralize and control the human
population
scarcity
the way they reacted to covet was insane
they gave us the two weeks to slow the
spread but then when we realized
people's eyes weren't bleeding like we
thought we where was the spread was done
like we okay let's open it back up now
but instead they went the other
direction we fought a civil war with
smallpox that had a death rate of 40
percent and we fought through it we
didn't like stop everything we didn't
like say okay you know we gotta we have
to bend the curve on this
things kept going people kept doing what
they were doing uh but in this sense i
mean it was like we allowed communism to
seep right into how many people would we
have allowed to enter into the the force
and die to fight communism from coming
into the united states how many
americans would we said okay that's
worth it to stop chinese communism from
coming into the united states hundred
thousand two hundred thousand five
million
we allowed it to come in through this
pandemic it just came right in and we
all just put a mask on our face and
stayed in home and it was the it was the
most brilliant execution if you're a
theorist if you're a conspiracy theorist
it was the most brilliant execution to
bring communism and to do a test run on
it then the pandemic was clash robert a
book called covet 19 the great reset
like he conflated the two things what do
those have anything to do with each
other unless he wants to make them
he talks about it he says that this is
our opportunity to enact the great did
you see that they ran that that
simulation in 2019 about what to do if
there was a global pandemic event 301
event through like they were ready for
it like really really ready for it right
before it happened constantly ready for
crises because i i think they understand
that's when they can make cultural moves
that's when they can make these huge
sweeping cultural changes is they're
waiting for a crisis if they can't make
if the crisis doesn't come they
manufacture it and um and they take
advantage of those moments it's you see
it throughout history every time these
crisis come along they try to make these
moves and they try to make these
cultural changes and i think that the
kovid was the perfect example and i
think it's multi-layered i think it's
not just covet i think the plan eve is
is even bigger uh than that because when
kobet first hit i was just screaming on
my youtube channel hey the economy is
going to get hit even way worse than
this and i think they calculated this
because they deliberately shut down
small mom-and-pop businesses they
allowed walmart to be open grandma down
the street had cops banged down a bust
down her door shut down her business
because she dared to even be open when
she was running an online business
having that kind of activity absolutely
destroyed the middle class the working
class and i think this was deliberate i
think a lot of the scarcity is
artificial and i think when you have
scarcity you're able to have control
over populations and i think right now
when it comes to the food sector the
energy sector we're seeing deliberate
compromises of those systems in order to
bring in more control for the ruling
party that's just my own personal
opinion and perspective from how i've
been seeing it and where things are
going ever since i learned about i was i
worked at ground zero over nine on 9 11
i actually worked in the american
express building across the street from
the pile from like october to
december and i would sit in this blown
out building
explode the walls were blown out the
windows were blown out i was like i
guess when a building falls all the
surrounding buildings windows get blown
out then later i start to find out
oh maybe maybe there's more concussive
forces at play you start to look the way
they butchered national institute of
standards and technology butchered the
the investigation into that thing and
just shipped off the the steel to china
they didn't invest and then there's all
these like scientists and engineers come
and say well there was trace amounts of
nano thermite found in the dust you look
at the buildings fall they're falling in
near freefall which indicates a
demolition but this silence the radio
silence on this makes me think that
people are complicit i don't know what
else to think i don't know who but but
it doesn't that wouldn't just happen on
accident you've got we're detectives man
we've got the cia
what look into this
why did those things seem to fall in
your free fall speed
it is it is a i've seen so many i
haven't gotten dug deep down into that
world i almost feel like it's
simple as they explained when the fires
weakened the steel
the weight of the upper floors caused it
to pancake creating an exponential
increase in force when the floor hits
another floor
so you would expect to see the pancaking
but that doesn't happen the whole thing
just falls well you
you wouldn't from all the debris and all
so you you can actually you can there's
blasts coming out of the windows and
it's funny because people are like ah
those are explosions they're like or
it's the pressure the firemen are like
there's a bombs going off on the
building pop pop pop pop pop pop all the
way up and you're like what are they
talking about
i got to slap you this is what i don't
like about conspiracy theories when news
reports came out on the day and it was a
lot of conjecture and confusion and
knowing what was going on
the conspiracy theorists tend to take
that and go wow that proved something
else happened i'm like or it proves that
you had no idea what the hell was
unfortunately i cannot prove what
happened well that's not my goal there's
a great group called the architects and
engineers for 911 truth and they've
garnered
thousands of professionals in the field
and they break it down more
scientifically and they explain things
through logic science and data
while of course nist and all these other
government officials have been hiding a
lot of the data and not highlighting it
to them i just i just want to make one
point on this because you know we're not
i don't think we're going to be able to
tackle this maybe maybe we'll talk about
it in the after show actually we'll go
in real great detail
i have a conspiracy theory you guys want
to hear it oh yeah during the
construction of the world trade towers
we're we're a country that operates on
uh the lowest bidder so there's a famous
quote i can't remember which astronaut
said this they said what was going
through your mind before that rocket
went off into space and he said that it
was built by the lowest bidder
so i imagine this you know there's a
point i make to a lot of conspiracy
theories because people will say stuff
they think like 9 11 was an inside job
or something and i say okay i hear you
why choose that conspiracy theory over
the other conspiracy theory that in the
70s when they were building this a
construction company the port authority
whatever they said we can build this for
x million dollars and they were like wow
that's cheaper than the other guy the
project is yours then the vp you know
goes to the cfo and he's like
are you nuts
we can't build this structure this big
for that price don't worry about it
we'll we'll skimp on this the stresses
in the center a plane's never going to
hit this building and so they rip off 30
million from the budget so they can get
the job done and then when it gets hit
it falls granted i i know there's a lot
of interesting things we'll talk about
but i'll put it this way
i think uh
people will choose their their end
result instead of starting from the
questions and then trying to understand
what happened and that's the issue i
take with it i got no issue of i'll tell
you this first and foremost 9 11 it was
a conspiracy either you believe it was a
conspiracy between you know these these
saudi nationals these egyptians and
these men to commit this act or you
think it was government actors or at the
very least they knew it was coming and
didn't care either way a conspiracy
occurred that day from that point we
should start asking questions about what
happened why did it happen how did it
happen
unfortunately we have two camps that
have
i'm not saying only two camps we have
two dominant camps one saying we know
what happened they're saying we know
what happened and i'm kind of like the
reality is the government's not going to
tell you what's going to happen there's
no way the government would ever tell
you the truth about 9 11. no sane
rational person would believe it thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there